hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
why mom night we're drinking some very
light white wine because I just ate my
weight in Chinese food so Cheers
now I know a lot of you guys watch this
series while you're drinking a glass of
wine you like wait till Saturday evening
you pour yourself glass and you watch
this so you guys are the best
you're my favorite wine drinking buddies
let's talk about the worst people to
drink wine wins
so first the know-it-all there's always
this one person who you're drinking wine
with and they're like oh this bottle was
harvested in their nether regions of
Netherlands they harvested the grapes at
the peak of winter so you can taste the
huckleberries Wow
I don't care where it's from I don't
care who made it I don't care how old it
was I have three questions for you when
we are drinking wine one do you have
wine too do you have a wine opener three
do I need to give a glass or can I just
drink it out of the bottle my only
exception to wine experts is Chris Webb
our friendly neighborhood sommelier he's
the best he's amazing he brings several
bottles of wine and I can sip my listen
to him talk next wine snobs these are
different from experts they're almost
worse than experts but there is always
this person who will invite you to a
party it's usually a dinner party and
you'll bring bottle of wine and they're
the biggest [ __ ] snob about it they're
like alum I only drink
Bordeaux's crafted in the 1800s sorry
this is like a 1940's and then if they
try the wine that you brought that's
subpar they make the biggest [ __ ]
deal out of it like they'll be holding
the white like I can't believe I'm
drinking this I never drink it's like
stop ruining everyone's time with your
[ __ ] ich miss wine all tastes the
same I think we can all agree that wine
tastes the same so to all you wine snobs
out there I'm calling you out I know it
all tastes the same and I know
you know it all tastes the same so stop
fronting next the people who think that
since you're drinking wine you have to
talk about the most boring stuff ever
whenever I'm drinking with a group of
adults all of a sudden they think that
since we're drinking wine the following
topics are the most fascinating things
on the planet
gardening vacations SoulCycle Downton
Abbey meal prep I want to type a fat
blue apron recipe yesterday with the
Thai chicken
I don't care and we're drinking wine I
want to talk about the important stuff
like what are we gonna order another
bottle - how are we gonna get home if we
order another bottle three
is there a donut place open this late
for does that doughnut place deliver I'm
talking about important stuff that's
what we should be discussing or we're
drinking wine next people who want to
drink wine anywhere besides here on my
couch and my friends are always like hey
I'm like for the price of one glass at
the wine bar I could have two bottles
here privacy of my own home in the
comfort of my own couch what's wrong
with Hannah's couch literally I will
offer to provide the line if we don't
have to go anywhere or they want to go
to a wine tasting I've tasted wine I
know what wine tastes like let's get a
nice selection from the father but let's
get a nice selection of wine from the
bottom shelf of the grocery store and
taste that cuz it all tastes the [ __ ]
same unless people who do measly pours
excuse me they wouldn't make the wine
glasses this big you were only supposed
to pour it this fall that doesn't make
sense I'm not drinking super nice stuff
that needs to like aerate and [ __ ] I
don't care when you order a beer they
pour the beer up to the top rim of the
glass because they made that glass for
the beer so why with wine
do they not do this same thing I want my
glass my full glass of wine
just like I'd expect a full glass of
beer hey you want to come on they say
that a bottle is five glasses I believe
that it's two and a half glasses if you
put your mind to it it looks like I got
four today I'm Hannah your friendly
neighborhood wine mom and if there was
anything I missed in this video leave it
in the comments what are the worst types
of wine drinkers you know and as always
if you want it with enough and as always
that there's topic you want me to
discuss in a future episodes leave it in
the comment the meantime I'm gonna
finish the thoughts of wine because the
ultimate worst people to drink wine with
are the people who waste wine but is it
weird if I pour this into my glass I
don't know where you've been but this is
perfectly good wine till next time
[Music]
that's it
[Music]